LET’S LISTEN IN TO JOE BIDEN.
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
THE ONLY COURT PACKING GOING ON
RIGHT NOW, IT’S GOING ON WITH
REPUBLICANS PACKING THE COURT
NOW.
IT’S NOT CONSTITUTIONAL WHAT
THEY’RE DOING.
THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON WHAT’S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
AND THE FACT IS THAT THE ONLY
PACKING GOING ON IS THIS COURT
IS BEING PACKED NOW BY THE
REPUBLICANS, AFTER THE VOTE IS
ALREADY BEGUN.
I’M GOING TO STAY FOCUSED ON IT
SO WE DON’T TAKE OUR EYES OFF
THE BALL HERE.
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> WELL, LOOK, BEFORE I CAME
OUT AGAIN TODAY TO GO SOMEWHERE,
I HAD ANOTHER TEST THIS MORNING
AND I’M CLEAR.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT THE
PRESIDENT MAKES SURE TWO THINGS.
ONE, THAT HE IS CLEAR, HE IS NOT
A SPREADER LIKE HIS -- LIKE DR.
FAUCI SAID A FEW SUPER SPREADER
EVENT HE HAD FOR THE SUPREME
COURT ANNOUNCEMENT AND SECONDLY,
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT THAT HE
MAKE IT CLEAR TO ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY SHOULD BE SOCIALLY
DISTANCED.
THEY SHOULD BE ON THE LAWN,
THAT’S FINE BUT IN FACT THEY
SHOULD BE SOCIALLY DISTANCED AND
WEARING MASKS.
THAT’S THE ONLY RESPONSIBLE
THING TO DO.
AND I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON